with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
building IOT applications on Google
Cloud stay tuned because here's the
rewind building an entire end-to-end IOT
application can feel overwhelming what
devices should I use how do I send my
data how do I make sure that
everything's secure once data gets
somewhere how do I get it into a data
store and once I have in storage how do
I actually use the data to do anything
useful half the battle in creating an
app is just knowing what technologies
are right for the job this is a pretty
typical architecture diagram for an IOT
application built on Google's cloud
platform this diagram even has a lot
going on in it but don't worry it's
alright I'm gonna walk us through it on
the topic of devices themselves I'm
gonna hand wave a little bit I mean when
that's done IOT already knows there's a
lot of debate going on right now around
hard what choice what sort of
communication protocol you want to
choose what data protocol is the best
one to use most of the time some
external factors going to make this
choice for you like you need devices on
the side of a mountain so pick whatever
works for the environment that the
device lives in and now that you've got
your hardware you need a good way to
keep track of all of them and connect
them to the cloud securely this is what
cloud IOT core is designed to do it's a
managed service and acts as a gateway
for your devices to Google cloud
platform
it handles registration of devices
securely connecting and communicating
with them and can even do things like
send configuration messages back down to
your devices once your devices are
sending their talent reuptake or these
telemetry payloads get bridged into our
event stream manager cloud pub/sub
events only stand pup's up for seven
days so we need to move them out of
there into permanent storage to do that
we pick cloud functions cloud functions
are serverless methods that can be
called directly with HTTP or fire in
response to some other event in our case
every device telemetry message coming in
fires the function which takes the data
from our hardware and pushes it into our
storage option cloud fire store fire
store is a no sequel database with very
low latency and for our purposes a
special sauce which is that it also has
a push update mechanism so our front-end
can subscribe to data updates and draw
our incoming telemetry data in real time
so a quick recap within the recap this
set up alone would be useful in terms of
during data for future use we've gone
from device through IOT core to pub/sub
and used a cloud function to pull that
telemetry data into cloud firestore so
what about visualization let me explain
no there's too much let me sum up we
built two front dies one an angular to
show off how easy it is to use our
batteries included JavaScript framework
to visualize real-time streaming data
and the other using Google sheets backed
by Apps Script to show off viewing raw
time windowed data we also created a
couple of administrative tabs one
enabled us to configure metadata in fire
store and the other hooked up to IOT
core admin SDK which allowed us to send
these configurations back down to our
devices that we had built obviously
there's more than one way to build an
IOT application I've run through just
the one happy path doing it here and the
products involved in our session a cloud
next we built this entire end-to-end
application while on stage as I talk
through what some of the other choices
are in Google cloud platform and showed
off some of the code that we were
writing while on stage I even ran around
the room while attached to our sensor
device to get some more interesting data
if you'd like to see the full talk check
out the link in the description below
don't forget to subscribe to the cloud
YouTube channel for more great next
rewind content thanks for watching
[Music]
you